these yemenis are preparing for a
long-awaited journey War closed off
sanaa's direct air road to Saudi Arabia
for years
now that it's reopened many are seizing
their chance
dressed in traditional clothes of the
Hajj programmers they plan to visit
Islam's holiest site in Mecca
I could not describe my feelings in
words we are so happy about the
reopening of Sana International Airport
we hope these flights remain open Sana
International Airport is the main
arrival gate to the country and our
connection to the world
airports are in the hands of houthis
until now that left government
controlled Aden as the only connection
to Saudi Arabia and getting there could
be dangerous
we were worried about traveling by land
towards Aiden's airport we were afraid
of problems along the road thank God we
can now travel this time I will travel
by Sana International Airport
the reopening of Sana airport is the
latest sign of progress towards ending
the war Saudi Arabia has long supported
the government against the houthis but
talks and prisoner exchanges have led to
Allah fighting and have raised hopes of
more permanent peace